there's no bigger
lebron supporter than nick wright of fox
sports one first things first
and uh their great co-host there is your
faith in lebron shaken at all nick
my faith in lebron no i i do think it's
pretty clear he's not 100
but i do think they will win tonight is
my faith in the lakers ability to win
the championship shaken it has to be
somewhat
i mean they went into the year the clear
favorites they didn't
really look like it after the first two
months of the season
and now you have to there's the
following things are all in question
if they get past phoenix which i think
they will by the way
when will anthony davis come back and
what anything davis are you getting
and even if anthony davis comes all the
way back
what has happened to dennis schroeder
we've seen different guys who get covid
be different players right after and
it's kind of it's a little bit of a
black box how much it affects everybody
but schroeder i thought was going to be
fine because games two and three he was
really good
but game four he was bad in game five he
was worse than you
dan and you didn't play but you at least
had zero points on zero shots schroeder
had zero points on nine shots so
all those things have shaken my faith
somewhat but sorry to filibuster but can
i give one positive
sure no
nothing in the world worse than
losing in the finals so
if he loses tonight at least lebron
won't have to worry about a final loss
and in fact in the chase of the the
infinite chase of michael jordan
he where jordan has the biggest lead is
first round losses he's up three to
nothing
so lebron could close that gap a bit
which is nice
uh better supporting cast the lakers are
the clippers
well are you saying after their top two
yeah
it's right now the clippers but
neither is great i think the clippers
for two years have had a bad roster
i've been the only person in america
who's been saying it i said it all year
last year
you don't have it you don't have a rim
protector and you don't have a point
guard
seems kind of important and this year
they're like got the rim protector
serge ibaka i'm like don't know like got
the point guard
who we're gonna trade for rondo okay
all right and then at the here's the
thing you know how i know the clippers
don't have a great roster
in the final minute of game five of the
postseason
nick batum and terence mann were on the
court no one was hurt
no one had fouled out that ain't great
yeah and and the clippers are puzzling
just because
they should know luca they should know
his game now
you got a former defensive player of the
year and kawhi leonard you got a great
two-way guard and paul george
i could at some point i got to get the
ball out of his hands
dan listen you obviously i consider
myself
as much of a basketball historian as one
can be but i uh and
i'm not trying to be sarcastic here
you've obviously been able to watch the
game longer than me
and i know people my generation
sometimes were a little more prisoner of
the momenty
so tell me if you think i'm i'm being
over the top here yeah
but i i think what we're seeing in lucca
is the makings of a guy who's going to
be one of the 10 greatest players ever
he dan he has played 11 career playoff
games
they have all been against kawhi and
paul george
so no first round series against a bad
you know pistons team with andre
drummond where you can just rack up
stats
he already has as many career
40 point playoff games as magic johnson
tim duncan and carl malone
he's only played 11 and it's open
against these guys and he has no
all-star teammates
what this reminds me of almost
line for line lebron's second year in
the playoffs
at age 22 with no other all-stars
it's like oh my god they're in the
finals yeah and luca
at age 22 in his second playoffs with no
other all-stars
and and dan he plays like how i assume
you play against frixie
like you get in front of him put your
butt on his hip and it's like you can't
get to the ball you can't get
it's insane he plays like they're little
kids out there and it's best players in
basketball
but i wonder though nick when the media
turns
on luca that this is a wonderful story
you're putting up great numbers
but lebron got to the nba finals with
one of the worst teams that's ever been
in the nba finals
and i wonder if like at some point
we want receipts from luca of can you do
what other great players have done
before well what if the mavs get to the
finals
oh that'd be that that that i don't
think it's out of bounds
i don't think it's out of the i don't
know how utah is going to deal with luca
utah's got a great defensive player in
gobert
who has almost no utility against luca
lucas not going to try to get to the rim
and so i i just think that you're right
eventually
uh if he eventually he's going to have
to show the receipts we
everyone giannis got a few years leeway
kd got a few
but katie got to the finals early he
just got beat by lebron but he got to
the finals early but then we started
coming for him a bit
after they blew the 3-1 lead to golden
state and that was a great team
so i agree with you that but i think
this is a hell of a start man
and i think you do have to start to
think last year
back when kristaps porzingis was a good
basketball player i don't know what's
happened to him would they have won that
series
if kristaps didn't get hurt and i think
so i thought they were the better team
last year and and this doesn't surprise
me it surprises me
of how dallas is still doing this like
they haven't really changed their game
plan it's just
luca go out and just see what you can do
and then
if somebody happens to get hot then
great you know tim hardaway will make
sure
you know we you'll get the ball uh you
know dorian finney like somebody
hey porzingis showed up it doesn't feel
like there's a whole game plan here
last night was also a great example of
why at times
like we all saw what dame did and dame's
game was special for a million reasons
but we give it
extra special quality because of what he
did in the fourth quarter in the
overtimes
we've always put an added importance on
what you do late in games
but sometimes that's unfair because
luca was clearly wiped at the end of
that
game why because when they tried to rest
him
earlier the moment he's off the court
they look like the worst offense in
basketball
so like he's everyone else is a little
fresher than him
late in the games because it's not only
that he's playing 40 plus minutes but
the ball in it is in his hands the
entire time
he stick right fox sports ones first
things first co-host
would you ask the question to anthony
davis
about charles barkley's new nickname for
him
like what do you mean you mean if i were
in the meat yeah i am in the media but
if i were a prescott
yeah i think that's a i think chuck
is not only if it was
let me put it like this if i had given
him that nickname then no one should ask
him about it
because i'm just an idiot who just talks
about basketball right
when it's a hall of famer when it's one
of the best to ever do it
who by the way you play basically the
same position even though it's very
different
i think that it's fair i think it's fair
to ask him
you know what do you yeah i think that
would be fair do you
do you think it wouldn't be i think it
just it depends on when you ask him
how you and now if he said yesterday at
the press conference hey i'm playing i'm
going to play in game six
uh hey uh is this any reaction to what
charles barkley
you know his new nickname you know
calling you street clothes
then at least it's um you know i can see
where people say
hey i'm not playing all the time these
are legitimate injuries but i'm playing
tomorrow night i got i don't know how
you ask it when you ask it
but i do think that it's there i mean it
was the there was the top
trending topic yesterday
that he called yeah i go ahead i'm sorry
no i'm just saying that it
it's a it's a it's a big deal and it's
the lakers
and and then it becomes even bigger and
i also think
that i i think that you chuck opens
himself
up and i know chuck a little bit you
know chuck really well
uh he opens himself up for guys to be
able to come back at him
which i think is would be totally fair
if a d
if if ad wanted to say wait is charles
barkley is saying that
i'm not in playing shape that's the
argument he's making like
there are things chuck's not impervious
to criticism of these things
i also think that you know
here's where i'll defend anthony i think
anthony probably hurt his groin
in part because he was playing through a
bad knee
right like so that was what the team
said yesterday was the doctor said
the hyper-extended knee right knee it
led to the groin injury at least they
think that the old kinetic chain thing
so maybe if he simply had sat out with
the knee injury
then maybe he's healthy for game five
the knees better and the groin doesn't
happen
and i think that this is gonna sound
silly
maybe a little silly we're kind of in a
post kevin durant world
which was people have burned the columns
but go back and read you know what was
being
implied in a lot of the bay area press
about kevin durant's recovery from the
calf injury
that the team is expecting him back and
even the owner of the warriors was like
we think kd
could be back any day now and then all
of a sudden he comes back and he pops
his achilles
right so i do think there is a bit of
concern about trying to push guys too
fast
i think what kevin durant has done in
the postseason has been
undersold dramatically like it's
i mean he was he was off for 500 days
i mean it this he i i
look at him and say that if you have a
shooter's menu a scoring menu he gets to
order
from whatever appetizer entree dessert
he'll just sort of go okay do i i
haven't hit a 15-footer in a while
you know i'm gonna i'm gonna hit a
runner you know i'm gonna take a three
point i'm gonna take you off the dribble
there's not many guys in the nba who can
do it he does
more without appearing to do more than
any player in the nba in my opinion
all right so he's showing seemingly no
ill effects from the achilles
which is unprecedented i understand the
celtics were overmatched and he
he again is in a beneficial position
because it's like the bizarro version of
luca
it's you can't focus all your defense on
katie you really have to single cover
him because the team he's on i get all
of that
but he's playing almost perfect
offensive basketball from an efficiency
standpoint
i i had somebody who is
i somebody that
is very very close with some a
different top player in the league not
kd make the argument that if you had
every player in league history standing
on a blacktop
and you were just describing their
traits to somebody who had seen none of
them play
that the unquestioned number one pick
based on traits would be durant
it's like okay tell me about this guy
okay well he's seven feet tall
he has handle like a guard he can
protect the rim he can score from
anywhere on the court
he's athletic he's you know he doesn't
have
a seeming weakness like if you describe
obviously i think lebron is a far
all-time greater player than durant
but if you described lebron in the same
scenario it's like well he's four inches
shorter
he's not as good of a ball handler and
he's not as good of a shooter
and so like durant when durant is full
go
and when he doesn't have the added
weight of
i have to do it all myself he's pretty
flawless man
uh before i let you go i i'm having a
hard time understanding
what the celtics are doing because i
have a
i have a great coach who now is my
president in gm who has to now hire a
coach
and the analogy i used was let's say
back in the mid 90s i'm doing
sportscenter
and i say kind of getting tired to burn
out a little bit could
i be a coordinating producer and head up
all of the sportscenter talent
like it doesn't make any sense like
right right but that's what i feel like
brad stevens
hey you're you're 44. you're a great
coach been to the eastern conference
finals
we're going to make you gm and now you
got to hire a coach
what what am i missing here i don't
understand it especially because
is the celtics job a perfect job no
tough to recruit free agents to that
city and
you don't have you're not missing draft
picks but amazingly danny ainge after
hoarding all these assets they have no
extra firsts
and they're in a tricky cap situation
but
it's almost assuredly the best gm job
that's going to come open
and so i would think you would call up
messiah yujiri
say hey you want to come run the celtics
right and by the way and maybe sam
presti
if sam presley's like listen i've left
the cupboard full for whomever's next
but man i don't want to do this
full rebuild i and it feels like you
you created a void in one of the few
spots you were set at
to create an unknown in another spot it
doesn't
you i agree with you entirely like it is
it is difficult to believe you're going
to get a coach better than stevens
and we have no reason to believe
possibly or negatively it's even going
to be a good gm
i don't get it i i totally i agree with
you 100 yeah you've now
i've created two questions instead of
one and and that is i could have kept
brad stevens as my head coach
and i could have gotten a gm i it's sam
presti
and brad stevens i that makes you
so much stronger it feels like and
now it feels like you've weakened
yourself unless unless those players
have tuned out brad stevens which i
i don't know it just feels like there's
something
that i there's a disconnect there
and i think nick's feed just froze up
it's a dramatic pause by nick um
it is it looks like he's really serious
he's baffled nailed that question uh my
thanks to uh nick wright joining us for
uh
fox sports one first things first yes
todd would you let nick know that uh
thank you very much
i will do that okay thank you very much